you changed
you stopped being you you let people
stick a finger in your face and tell you
you're no good and when things got hard
you started looking for something to
blame
like a big shadow
let me tell you something you already
know the world ain't all sunshine and
rainbows it's a very mean and nasty
place and i don't care how tough you are
it will beat you to your knees and keep
you there permanently if you let it
you me or nobody is gonna hit as hard as
life
but it ain't about how hard you hit it's
about how hard you can get hit and keep
moving forward how much you can take and
keep moving forward
that's how winning is done
now if you know what you're worth now go
out and get what you're worth but you
got to be willing to take the hits and
not pointing fingers saying you ain't
where you want to be because of him or
her or anybody
cowards do that and that ain't you
you're better than that
i'm always gonna love you no matter what
no matter what happens
you're my son you're my blood
you're the best thing in my life
but until you start believing in
yourself you're gonna have a life
that ladies and gentlemen is how you
start the day a lot of us drink the
coffee or the chai
or a little water with lemon but that
rocky balboa from the movie rocky balboa
talking to his son about what life is
and how you go get it
that is what it is all about and you
will see
why i open the show with that
i'm dave rubin by the way this is the
reuben report direct message it's april
14
20
22
and there is a lot going on in the world
the theme of today's
show
is that the tide is turning i really
believe it people and i want to declare
today
officially
day one of
the post
woke world look at that we even made a
little banner put it back up little
banner to say
day one
post woke world there is good stuff
happening i have been telling you guys
it's not enough to complain about it we
gotta figure out how to fight back
exactly what rocky said the world is
tough we've all realized that we've been
stuck in the muck in the mire of this
woke bs but there are signs that we can
win and as you probably have heard if
you've been on the computer machine
today
we got a massive freaking sign just in
the last few hours elon musk is trying
to buy all of twitter this story that
we've been tracking over the last two
weeks he's making his freaking move and
in a big way and i'm gonna link that to
a bunch of other things going on
individuals he's just one guy i'm just
one guy you're just one guy or gal i'm
not a biologist i don't know what you
are but all of us are just one person
and if we stand up to this machine i
think we can see that it actually is a
wet paper bag and it will fold that is
the theme of today's show i am amped up
and ready to roll want to remind you
guys i am going on tour kicking it off
this tuesday
in west palm beach with donald trump jr
at the palm beach improv then i'm in
clearwater florida with benny johnson
raleigh north carolina with andrew
clavin atlanta georgia with michael
malus chicago illinois with janme park
dallas texas with glenn beck washington
dc with megan mccain west niacc new york
with megan kelly brea california with
dennis prager
oxnard california with larry elder san
jose california with douglas murray
phoenix arizona with blake masters and
charlie kirk and denver colorado with
brian callan you can get your tickets at
daverubin.com
events and again all the vip tickets
keep selling out so i think we just
added a couple more this morning by the
way just fyi facebook is not letting us
put ads on the tour we are working
through that right now so if you haven't
seen anything on facebook which is where
most people buy tickets to things
they're not letting us put ads and i'm
not allowed to put ads on twitter
because i was suspended back in july for
warning that mandates vaccine mandates
were coming so even though they
unsuspended me they suspended my ad
account on there so i'm fighting the
freaking machine people and elon musk is
fighting the machine and today is day
one of a post woke world i'm not kidding
i think we can do this i think there's
signs so let's
roll uh the big story of the day and
we've got a quote from reuters
billionaire elon musk offers to buy
twitter for 41.39
billion dollars a regulatory filing
shows okay so this is this is pretty
powerful stuff now if you weren't paying
attention for the last two weeks you may
remember that uh about a week and a half
ago or so he bought this first 9.2
of twitter which made him the largest
stakeholder in twitter uh but he was not
obviously a majority shareholder right
he didn't own over 50 of it but he was
the largest individual stakeholder then
he said he was going to get on the board
they offered him a seat they had a
couple tweets going back and forth
between him and the the ceo of twitter
and the former ceo of twitter and all
that and everybody's playing nice but
then of course the the woke activists
that are in the company because they've
been eating this company alive much like
disney's employees are eating disney
alive and all of these companies are
being eaten alive by activist employees
who should have no right to direct a
company you're an employee you get a
check do your job go home get a life
then it started getting weird so elon
musk said he wasn't going to take the
board seat because if he had taken
the board seat that would have kept him
at about 14 and a half percent that's
just the way the rules work and he would
have never been able to do a hostile
takeover meaning just take over the
whole freaking company so a few days ago
that's what he said i'm not taking the
board seat actually twitter at 11 p.m on
sunday night announced that he wasn't
taking the board seat and it led to this
and it is freaking
beautiful here is the letter from elon
musk to brett taylor the chairman of the
board
at twitter
from elon i invested in twitter as i
believe in its potential to be the
platform for free speech around the
globe and i believe free speech is a
societal imperative for a functioning
democracy however since making my
investment i now realize the company
will neither thrive nor serve the
societal imperative in its current form
twitter needs to be transformed as a
private company as a result i am
offering to buy 100
of twitter for 54.20
per share in cash my offer is my best
and final offer and if it is not
accepted i would need to reconsider my
position as shareholder twitter has
extraordinary potential i will unlock it
elon musk can you guys let me know the
the shares of twitter what are they
worth right now because he's paying a
massive premium on those shares i am
sure they are worth much less than that
50 plus dollars they're yeah they're
worth right now twitter's shares is this
as of this morning because i would love
to know what they were even yesterday if
they jumped so right now twitter's
shares are
46.47 a share so he's tacking on about
six dollars a share okay uh that's
yesterday's oh and yesterday it was
45-44 so it went up because of elon okay
you understand what's going on here and
he is saying i will pay another roughly
six dollars per share just to take the
whole freaking thing right now so there
is a massive war brewing and just
understand and this is why i wanted to
do this as the theme of the show we have
watched the woke monster destroy
everything we have allowed companies
like twitter like disney uh all of these
companies the list goes on and on right
we have watched all the commercials you
watch just absolutely everything we have
watched all of these companies push
their woke ideology on us we have
watched them censor us we have watched
them ban people they have allowed us to
say what you can say and what you can't
say who can say what when they can say
it all of it and here's one guy now he's
a pretty extraordinary guy right he's
the he's the iron man of our time
right
but he's just one man and he's saying i
am putting my money where my mouth is
think of the freaking headaches that
this is gonna cause for elon musk right
like this is a guy he could literally be
like you know what i've just had about
enough of earth i'm getting on my own
rocket ship that will be the most
mind-blowing freaking thing ever and i'm
going to spend the rest of my life going
to mars and then i'm going to build a
colony on mars and i'm going to have my
own planet that's what he could do and
that would actually be pretty cool and
maybe he will do that but instead he
said i'm going to put 50 freaking
billion dollars
is that the number is it 50 50 billion
total what's the total number 100 of
twitter what's the actual number that
he's going to put down here it it's
incredible it doesn't even matter what
the number is we'll get the oh yeah
41.39 billion dollars i'm gonna put it
doesn't even matter whether he has a
gajillion dollars or not but he's saying
i will do something there is a problem
we all know there's a problem and i will
do something and this is how you
freaking fight back
i happen to write a book about that sort
of thing in case you're interested it's
still number one on most of the amazon
charts if you want to check it out
book but we are now going to go into a
half hour of how you fight back because
you're going to see we're going to have
to keep fighting because they're going
to keep moving they are going to keep
moving either way and we're seeing it
whether it's inflation or bringing back
masks or the rest of the nonsense but i
think this is a marker and that is why i
am declaring this today day one of a
post woke world we finally let's see it
again post get it up there it is post
woke day one because we've just needed a
signal we just needed a bat signal to go
oh there's something out there there's
somebody out there who might be brave
enough to do something and i think it's
starting to happen but it won't be fully
saved by him and it won't be fully saved
by ron desantis and it won't be fully
saved by me or anyone else it'll
actually be saved by you because the
signal is the thing right the signal is
what sends something to you to go what
can i do in my life to fight the thing
so that is what we are talking about
today get me my boxing gloves that's how
we're ending this show i want to go
fight ivan drago uh all right we got an
ad for you
iced coffee today uh let's talk about
get upside you know from cringing at the
pump to getting an eye-popping check at
your favorite restaurant inflation is
hitting us all where it hurts and it
really hurts that's why i started using
get upside get upside is an incredible
app for anyone who buys gas groceries or
dines out with every purchase you're in
cash back thanks to get upside to get
started download the free getupside app
in the app store or google play use my
promo code ruben how do we come up with
that and get five dollars or more cash
back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more next claim an offer for
whatever you're buying on get upside
check in at the business pay as usual
with the credit or debit card and get
paid get upside isn't just for gas you
can earn up to 30 cash back at grocery
stores restaurants and on food delivery
as well in comparison to credit card
rewards or loyalty programs you can earn
three times more cash back with get
upside you can cash out any time to your
bank account paypal or e-gift card for
amazon and other brands get upside users
are earning more than million dollars
every week that's probably why they have
a 4.8 star rating on the app store
download the free get upside app and use
promo code ruben to get five dollars or
more cash back on your first purchase of
ten dollars or more that's five dollars
more cash back on your first purchase of
10 bucks or more using promo code rubin
okay let's talk about fighting back
because i mentioned to you guys
yesterday
philadelphia which is in the once great
state one of our first states of the
union pennsylvania it is reinstituting
the mass mandate that is in stark
contrast with what's going on right here
in the free state of florida so here is
solution number one in the post woke
world do not back down
with ron desantis
in the last week or so we've seen major
outbreaks of coven 19 among
the elite and dc including democrats in
congress the biden administration how
does it feel to read about that news
knowing that the administration has been
so critical of your approach to the
pandemic
so just let me say it very clearly to
all floridians you just saw philadelphia
impose an indoor mandate
you're going to have potentially some of
these other deep blue jurisdictions go
back to restrictions and mandate you
look what's happening in shanghai they
have everybody under a brutal lockdown
so i just want to be very clear
as long as i sit in the chair in which i
sit
no floridian will be restricted mandated
or locked down in any possible way
that's right mr governor so what's going
on exactly in philadelphia right now
well we've got some info from the daily
wire philadelphia will mandate indoor
masking on april 18th the city's health
department announced monday the
announcement came as a new variant ba.2
continues to sweep across the nation the
paper cited health commissioner sheryl
bedegal as saying the number of cases
have prompted the move
complete and utter
nonsense at this point if you are a
philadelphian whether you work at the
cream cheese factory or you clean the
rocky statue
up over at the top of the stairs you
should not listen to this these people
do not deserve your attention and your
respect any longer if you would like to
wear a mask
uh at phil in philadelphia then wear a
mask
two years ago guys we're past two years
from two weeks to flatten the curve okay
we're past the point
but now this is spreading because we
sort of got post covert right we did our
war thing the ukraine russia war thing
for about six weeks we seemingly were
getting past covet nobody was talking
about it anymore but now it's coming
back they're bringing it back and what
happened yesterday well they decided
that the mask mandate on planes is going
to continue we've got some info from
cnbc
the biden administration is extending a
mask mandate for airplanes and transit
for 15 days the cdc said on wednesday
the mandate was set to expire after
april 18th following a one-month
extension announced in march airlines
have required masks on planes since
early in the coveted pandemic in 2020
but the obama administration made them
mandatory in early 2021. okay again on
the plane situation every time you get
on a plane they show you a video often
cartoon or sometime a very botoxed uh
woman and she's got the big thing and
it's a green gun and they're spraying
the plane and the man's got the mask and
then they tell you that we filter out
99.9 they tell it it's a fast you know
it's the safest error known to man and
blah blah blah
but it has nothing to do with that
once again they will just push you they
will just push you and push you and push
you and the same day that philly is
bringing back the masks is the same day
that the cdc is extending
the situation on the planes and of
course that is backed by the biden
administration so what do you have to do
what do you have to do you have to do
what rocky balboa said at the top of the
show you have to realize that you have
to do something about your life you have
to do what ron desantis just said
no no no more sorry no more we will not
do this anymore
but of course here's uh lord fauci who
again has gotten everything wrong the
entire way explaining why the mask
mandate was extended well let's talk
about
the fact first of all that we understand
that the tsa is going to extend that
mass mandate for public transportation i
know it's not announced yet but that is
our reporting uh so given the fact that
we're still seeing the surge in europe
uh we're still seeing the effects here
in the northeast
why only 15 days
well i think angie because it's a moving
target and we really want to see what
the pattern is here in the united states
i think making a decision for april 18th
uh i would agree that we really do need
more time it isn't like things are
static
things are moving we're seeing an
increase
throughout the country we're seeing it
more so in certain cities in certain
regions than others and until we get a
really good handle on it
i think it's prudent i mean i don't know
what the official word has been about
that
but if they do extend it i would not be
surprised and i think that that would be
a prudent thing to do
philadelphia is bringing back its indoor
mask mandate as of next week as well
okay so as always no numbers from fouchy
no explanation it's these vague terms
and it would be prudent and we'll have
to see and numbers drop and go up
there's just never an honest assessment
of anything with this clown uh he also
called andrea mitchell angie her name is
angela not angie but putting that aside
but even the way that she framed it did
you hear the way that she framed it why
only 15 days
uh you crazy msnbc harpy do you remember
it was 15 days to flatten the curve two
years ago what an insane like you
legitimately have to be a crazy person
you have to be a crazy person or a true
psychopath to think that anthony fauci
should have the authority at this point
to have any
authority over anyone's life
mask-related mandate related or anything
else now this because i want solutions
we're looking for solutions but i've got
to show you one more thing before
solutions you may remember
this video we showed you i think it was
yesterday kamala harris
she's wearing masks or not wearing masks
but it really just depends on how
important the event that she's going to
is according to jen soccer last question
you said on friday that the vice
president was masked indoors all day
but the white house tweeted a video
showing her standing over the president
without a mask on can you explain what
happened there well i would say that the
vice president and the president and all
of us abide by what the cdc protocols
are it was an emotional day it was a
historic day and there were moments when
she was not wearing a mask inside
including in a photo but she was wearing
it 99.9 percent of the time
yeah she was wearing it 99.9 percent of
time just epic [ __ ] like epic
[ __ ] okay and then this uh we abide
by cdc protocols but you know it was a
very important day we'd have to pull up
the cdc protocols but i'm sure there's
an asterisk on there and it says but if
you're doing something that's really
important you know what i mean if you've
got a uh you know a supreme court
nominee that's getting and then it's
okay or a wedding or a bris then it's
all right cope can't you know
okay you got it so what do you do what
do you do because now we're talking
solutions you don't just stand your
ground and take it that's what you don't
do you call out their [ __ ] ron
desantis ladies and gentlemen you look
over the last two years
there's a cottage industry that was
developed of lockdown politicians and
media personalities who would either
impose or support lockdown policies in
their jurisdictions or advocated on
their tv shows criticize florida
mercilessly and then the first chance
they get to get out from under the yoke
of those bad policies you see them in
miami or palm beach or all these other
places and if i had a dollar for every
lockdown politician that escaped their
own policies to come to our free state i
would be set for life that's just the
fact now some people will say oh they're
hypocrites all this stuff yeah they are
but that's not the issue the issue is is
if they thought their policies really
were necessary and these mitigations
really were effective they would be
abiding by it they're not abiding by it
because they know it's all about
politics and control so that's why they
don't wear the mask that's why they
don't do all this stuff because they
know
it is covid theater and so we don't have
any tolerance for cobit theater in the
state of florida i can tell you this
state would not be booming the way it is
if we had had had coveted theater people
know that this is the free state they
know that they can come here and make
their own decisions they know they're
not going to be harassed to show medical
papers to go have a hamburger somewhere
they know they're going to be able to
enjoy life and so we are never going to
waver for that i will say
that you know if it weren't for our
leadership you know we would have had
kids locked out of school for a year
throughout this state we would have had
hundreds of thousands of people tossed
out of work we would have had
small businesses and family-owned
businesses that would have collapsed um
and instead of that uh you know we
weren't locking those people down we
were lifting them up and that was the
right thing to do
the truth
it's refreshing we should trademark that
you guys want to get a hamburger today
you talked about the hamburgers without
the masks you guys want hamburgers
hamburgers for everybody cheese for you
all right we're getting hamburgers today
shake shack people
in case you ain't feeling juiced up yet
and you should be feeling juiced up
right now because we gave you rocky we
gave you elon musk we gave you desantis
i'm going to talk to you about inflation
a second that's going to depress you but
before we do that i want to talk to you
about super beats you know as we age the
fatigue and lack of endurance we feel
can't always be fixed with more and more
caffeine introducing a new way to start
your day super beets heart chews they're
a tasty treat that gives you the energy
you need and are good for you no more
afternoon coffees energy drinks and
candy for a quick pick-me-up add two
delicious plant-based super beat heart
shoes to your morning routine and
promote heart-healthy energy for your
day without caffeine crash because super
beats heart chews our unique clinically
researched grape seed extract because
they promote heart healthy energy and
normal blood pressure as part of a
healthy lifestyle i mumbled that a
little bit but you got the idea
the grape seed extract used in super
beets heart shoes has clinically shown
to be two times as effective at
supporting normal blood pressure as a
healthy lifestyle alone do more for your
heart and treat yourself with super
beats heart choose for my listeners only
you can get up to 45 off plus free
shipping at superbeats.com reuben this
is their best offer available anywhere
that's superbeats.com reuben for up to
45 off at superbeats.com reuben and i
did toss in two of those this morning
they're sort of like gummy bears
tossed them in and maybe that's why i'm
so amped up today it is quite possible
okay so now let's talk about inflation
because even though we are fighting back
they are going to keep coming they are
an unstoppable rebel force but we are
going to stop them they think they're
unstoppable but they are not the secret
uh here's jensaki this is monday a
warning of the high inflation situation
so because of the actions we've taken to
address uh putin the putin price hike we
are in a better place than we were last
month
but we expect march cpa cpi headline
inflation to be extraordinarily elevated
due to putin's price hike and we expect
a large difference between core and
headline inflation reflecting the global
disruptions in energy and food markets
so chlorine inflation doesn't include
energy and food prices uh headline
inflation does
putin's price like putin's price act
putin's price hike it has nothing to do
with them uh printing all this money it
has nothing to do with them giving out
all this money it has nothing to do with
any of the ridiculous
policies that they have instituted it's
putin's price hike it's almost as if
these people have nothing to do with
anything happening right now it's quite
extraordinary they keep putting on their
fancy outfits and they keep giving
speeches and they stand at lecterns and
they do all of this stuff but they don't
have anything to do with anything going
on it's just this guy in russia who can
do whatever he wants to us at any point
quite extraordinary wouldn't you say
but we've got actual numbers
from nbc today the rising cost of
everyday life in this country new
numbers confirming what we already know
inflation is skyrocketing reaching a
41-year high we're getting a sense of
exactly how much it is costing the
average american family nbc's tom
costello on the story again for us tom
good morning
yeah we are seeing higher prices for
everything for food for housing for used
cars but the biggest driver of this last
month
energy fuel gas prices now the bite
administration is adding more ethanol
into the summer blend hoping that that
will in fact help drive down gas prices
the bottom line though experts say the
impact may be minimal
many americans have known it for a long
time but now it is official inflation is
skyrocketing hitting 8.5 percent last
month the highest since 1981.
a big driver gas prices which a new
government forecast predicts will reach
an eight year high this summer while
right now prices are down 24 cents from
their highs in march the national
average still four dollars eight cents a
gallon up a dollar 22 cents from a year
ago now the biden administration is
announcing a temporary summertime waiver
to allow for the sale of e-15 a blend of
gas with 15 percent ethanol even if it's
an extra buck or two in the pockets and
they fill up will make a difference in
people's lives but adding more ethanol
may have a limited impact since only one
and a half percent of gas stations
nationwide actually carry e15 it's not
just energy prices that are fueling
inflation food is up 8.8 percent year
over year the biggest annual increase in
41 years you literally cannot make this
[ __ ] up their their solution is to put
more ethanol
in the gas which is not good for the
cars that's why the ethanol is not there
in the first place and only 1.5
of the gas stations allow for this right
okay do you realize how insane these
people are but it has nothing to do with
them because there is a scary man in
russia and he rides a horse without a
shirt
and he must be stopped at all costs it
is complete and utter nonsense it is a
total shell game they do all of the
stuff that has ransacked and wrecked the
economy this was not happening under
scary orange man and then they blame
shirtless horse-riding russian guy get
rid of your vodka if you're a true
american uh but they also try to scare
the hell out of you the entire time
because if they didn't do the stuff that
they're doing you'd be starving
responsibility for his decisions like
some say the american rescue plan
boosted demand uh when it didn't need to
larry summers was one of those well the
alternative would have been uh that we
would have gone into a massive economic
downward spiral and many americans would
have not had enough food to put on the
table so we chose the other path
can you believe it guys if they hadn't
done all this good stuff that they've
been doing printing money out of nowhere
and all of the great things that this
administration is doing you wouldn't
have food on the table you'd be
absolutely starving sure your food is
extremely expensive and your gas is
extremely expensive and there's not as
much stuff on the shelves and everything
is taking forever to get delivered
actually we're trying to just paint our
guest bedroom white we're going to turn
a guest bedroom into the baby's room we
just want to literally paint it white
and the contractor came yesterday and he
said that paint white paint is four
times as expensive as it was last year
but thank you saki i'm not starving to
death i do have some frozen meat in the
fridge
so in the freezer in the in the garage
there but she continued uh joe biden is
leading the economy this is the man
leading the whole thing even though he
has nothing to do with anything that's
going on here also the world also needs
to see her the country needs to say i
guess i should say uh how he is
continuing to lead on the economy and i
don't know that that's a shift or
requiring a shift it's just a
recognition that uh being able to
continue to speak to domestic or
domestic audience about that is a huge
priority and his schedule tells the
story of how much of a priority is
it's not even double speak with these
people because then it would be saying
one thing and then saying the opposite
they literally their head is just
spinning saying endless [ __ ] that
has no connection to reality whatsoever
there was a guy in he-man can you look
up the character at he-man manny faces
that you don't have to look it up i got
it man there was a character in he-man
named manny faces and his face would
just flip around and he would just have
different faces on and that's what these
people are
masters of the universe that's the the
answer to the quiz show today um but
okay biden's leading now first they're
telling us that it's because of putin's
price hike but apparently it's really if
it wasn't about that it's that biden is
leading and he has to show us he's
leading how's he leading well remember
this
with regard to food shortage yes we did
we
still talk about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real
the price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries and our country as
well
that's leadership people food shortages
are coming and we're putting the
sanctions on that are causing them
leadership 101. if you look in the
dictionary under leadership it has joe
biden's confused face but you know that
the state of all of this is whacked out
when even on cnn the fictitious cartoon
network known as cnn when even they
even democrat activist jake tapper has
to acknowledge that some of this is bs
we were covering inflation long before
putin invaded ukraine inflation in the
united states in the last year
is
preceded this attack
and some people hear the president and
the white house blaming all of this on
putin and think
that's just not accurate that's just not
factual
hot diggity damn can we send uh jake
tapper a gift basket
what do we got we got some florida
orange we're gonna send him a copy of
the book tapper you got one right
i lost a bet who knew
it's not just cnn then there's this
mental institution msnbc with that
racist joy read they're even
acknowledging what's going on look at
this image very look at this up all the
stuff that you don't want up you'd want
down right now and generally speaking
you'd want down unless you were a
partisan maniac everything's up gas is
up about 50 used automobiles i mean this
is insane or up 35 because we're not
producing enough new ones hotels up 25 i
know all about that as i'm trying to go
on tour right now airfare i know all
about this one too about 24
furniture and bedding 16
meat poultry and eggs you guys all know
this when you're going shopping everyone
sees it major appliances are up cereal
baked goods about 10
this is all obvious and we know it but
it has nothing to do with them on one
hand because this is putin's price hike
but also joe biden's in charge and he
has to show people he's in charge none
of it makes sense so people
what is
the thing that ties today's show
together
you can either believe that these people
are in charge and are doing a good job
or you can believe that they are in
charge but actually it's putin who's
really in charge or you can believe that
they are intentionally wrecking any
everything or some version of all of
those things
or you can take a little responsibility
for your life
you can perhaps somehow in your life do
what elon musk is doing in his life and
i know it doesn't sound quite right it's
like wait a minute this guy's like a
trillionaire he's sending teslas into
space he's going to mars all of this
stuff it's like i'm i'm in no way
related to elon musk but he is one man
he is one human being and he started
doing something so whatever it is in
your life that you can do
whether it's you start growing some food
in your backyard which they don't want
you to do
whether it is that you cancel disney
plus that they don't want you to do
whether it is that you get your kids out
of public school so they don't believe
these clowns when they say this nonsense
that would be good there is a whole
bunch of stuff that you can do you can
stand your ground you can call out their
bs
and you cannot vote for democrats you do
not have to be a republican but you
cannot be a democrat that is the message
and spread that to your friends and
start getting some balls really more
than anything i guess that's really what
it is start getting some balls today is
post woke day one
i'm not a mathemagician but that means
that tomorrow is post woke day two and
imagine if after years of this woke
[ __ ] imagine if after years of this
slow descent to hell that they have
dragged us into imagine if whatever it
is in your life right so this is a
little bit of jordan peterson kind of
stuff you got to fix yourself before you
fix the world but imagine if you started
doing it and i'm talking to myself too
if all of us started doing it and we
started standing up straight with our
shoulders back we started putting truth
into the world we started fighting for
what we believe in we started saying no
as they kept encroaching on us and
encroaching on our kids and and lying
about everything imagine if we all did
that and we did it for a week
do you think things would be better or
worse
i bet that they'd be better
i'd bet that they'd be better uh we got
some comments from
reubenreport.locals.com aaron says the
renewal of masks on public
transportation for two more weeks is
beyond unscientific of course it is it
has nothing to do with science we know
if you wear a mask you touch your face
more they even they even admitted after
two years they finally admitted that the
cloth masks and basically everything
beyond except for n95s because you have
openings and you can breathe through the
top or you can breathe through the
bottom or you can breathe through the
side they literally did
nothing and in some studies they've
shown that they do less than nothing
because you touch your face more we all
do it we're constantly adjusting the
thing it's not fun when you actually
have to communicate with somebody you
pull them i haven't worn a mask in song
i really don't remember but it's
something like when you were talking to
somebody you'd be away from each other
with the mask and then you'd be talking
and nobody could hear anybody with the
mask and then you pulled oh
jerry can elon start a members only
airline so sane people can return to
travel i'm not kidding
my one goal in life now is to become so
rich i have a plan and i know that's an
extraordinary amount of money and i'll
let people ride the plane because once
you have the plane i don't need to fly
every day so i don't know what do we
have to do an nft thing we're trying to
figure out the nft situation i'm gonna
do an nft
i don't know exactly what that means but
that the kids are saying it's the thing
now we're gonna do an nft i'm gonna buy
a plane and you guys can ride my plane
i'm not kidding i want a plane people
can ride the plane i'll probably you
know fly here and there but on the off
days we'll get a cool pilot we'll get uh
that lizzo maybe she could sing on the
plane that's too much too much weight
it'll cost us too much in gas forget the
lizzo um we're gonna get it's just gonna
we're doing it
rock says uh we switched to a private
school so my kids could be at a mask
choice school yes that's the point
private schools charter schools home
schools pods
you can do something
you can do something to remove yourself
from the system the system doesn't
deserve your attention or respect if it
is not going to respect you back if it
is only going to do bad things and take
more and more for you from you then it
then it doesn't deserve whatever you're
going to give it whatever your resources
are i don't mean just financial your it
doesn't deserve your attention and your
brain power and your skills and all of
those things that is the answer so it's
a combination of all of these things
removing yourself building new things
fighting back calling out the hypocrisy
doing what rocky balboa said doing what
ron de santa said doing what elon musk
is saying
and dare i say doing what they've ruben
say
ladies and gentlemen i'm on tour dave
rubin.com events join us it kicks off on
tuesday we can't put ads anywhere on big
tech but i promise you we are actually
going on tour i hope you will join us
we'll be hitting florida and texas and
colorado and california all over the
place oh by the way you can also see uh
did a little interview with my main man
david janet we put the first part up on
youtube the rest of it's on locals
people like it people are saying they
like him more than me
i like him more than me it's totally
fine uh the full thing is up at
reubenreport.locals.com part two of my
interview with michael knowles he
actually interviewed me about that book
right there that's up right now and in
summation we've never done this before
but i felt it was important on a day
like today
as i have henceforth declared this
post-woke world and we are in post-woke
world day one we are going to do
the same cold close
as the cold open enjoy you changed
you stopped being you you let people
stick a finger in your face and tell you
you're no good and when things got hard
you started looking for something to
blame
like a big
let shadow tell you something you
already know
the world ain't all sunshine and
rainbows it's a very mean and nasty
place and i don't care how tough you are
it will beat you to your knees and keep
you there permanently if you let it
you me or nobody is gonna hit as hard as
life
but it ain't about how hard you hit it's
about how hard you can get hit and keep
moving forward how much you can take and
keep moving forward
that's how winning is done
now if you know what you're worth now go
out and get what you're worth but you
got to be willing to take the hits and
not pointing fingers saying you ain't
where you want to be because of him or
her or anybody
cowards do that and that ain't you
you're better than that
i'm always gonna love you no matter what
no matter what happens
you're my son you're my blood
you're the best thing in my life
but until you start believing in
yourself you're gonna have a life